- You make that choice,
either you can go this way
where it's all bad and
cloudy and feel like a victim
or you could feel like
you've conquered everything
that they told you that you couldn't do
and be out here winning, so it's like,
psh, let me go over here and win.
(uplifting music)
I started realizing that
something was off with my body
when I was around 14 years old.
After awhile, my mom was in
her room and she called me
to the back and she
was like, you have ALS.
And I was like, okay.
And she was like, do
you know what that is?
And I was like, no.
The role my family and
friends play into my life
is so significant.
My mom flew down.
They didn't start babying
me, they didn't tell me
anything negative, anything
that I said I wanted to do,
they supported it, it was
senior year in high school
and we went to grad night
Disneyland and because
Disneyland was so big, the
school nurse recommended
that I use a motorized wheelchair
and it was so convenient
for me, I was like,
well college is almost
as big as Disneyland,
I might as well start using a chair.
And that's the thing, is like
I know people will probably
see me in my wheelchair and
think, oh it's a wheelchair,
it's the worst thing that
could ever happen to somebody
but in my case and I do
have to put the disclaimer
that every person with a
disability is different,
if I would have kept walking,
I probably would have been
more permanent in the chair.
One of the major reasons why
I even started my YouTube
was because I wanted
to show that disability
didn't look sad, it didn't look sloppy,
it didn't look medical, it
could be fly, it could be sexy,
it could be fun, it could be
whatever you wanted it to be.
Because it's so annoying as
a person with a disability
when people think that you
should look a certain way.
There's been so many times
where people will come up to me
if I'm not in my chair and be like,
well you don't look disabled.
What the fuck is that supposed to mean?
Oh so you think I'm
supposed to be here like,
oh I'm sad, my life is the
worst, and it's just like no,
sorry, I sit high.
So the average life
expectancy for a person
who was diagnosed with ALS
is about five to seven years
and given the fact that I'll be 30.
I've doubled the life
expectancy and then some.
I used to have a fear
that because I was a woman
in a wheelchair, that I
wouldn't be able to do as much
as I wanted but I always
have to get back centered
and just remember, in this
moment, you can either
harp on all the things
that haven't happened yet,
all the fears which is just a
thought, it's not even real,
or you can look at what is real.
You still have the ability to walk,
you still have the ability to stand,
you still have the ability
to speak and open your eyes
and with that alone,
it's like, you know what,
I'm going this way and
remind myself that I'm always
going to push through, I'm
always gonna stay positive
and I'm going to do the best that I can
to be the best version of
me, 'cause I sit high boo.
(upbeat music)